this isn't a dude right that
that sits idle that's nepotism this
isn't a dude
that comes from hollywood royalty
right this is a dude that went to
colombo columbia university
right came out here waited i mean what
couldn't wait tables hosted couldn't
wait hosted at places right
and but what i love about it is is that
it's a guy that everything that you have
right
wasn't handed to you you are the one
because for
imagine making phone calls to [ __ ]
you know companies
going hey can i i don't even know who to
call pr pr department
you know i mean hi you know imagine
doing all the footwork
that you need to do and it's so funny
about him
because if you look back at diplo
when i told my agent no right that
wasn't enough for him
he went to andy andrew santino and go
dude you gotta
make the call convince him right most
people are like oh we'll have to find
somebody else
not this guy he knew who what he wanted
right so he made the effort and i'm sure
that even if the andrew santino didn't
work out he would find another another
angle my point is is that you know
that's just
who he is i know what other angle he
would have taken after andrew what
he would have used the mad tv connection
to the character that you played what
right
no who who did you play who did i play
where
it's like yeah just go ahead
go ahead no no no go ahead what do you
mean the mat you played a manager right
i played a man oh okay that's right
there you're right yeah oh god
wait what no this is it this is it
so you mean through clyde yes
so in diplo show i play a manager
who's based on a real guy and his name
is
kevin kevin i love kevin so kevin
the guy that i played on your show
you're right now okay okay so there
right so but i'm a hustler too yes
so too but when i was on mad tv
kevin's dad frequently did mad tv
because i always requested him because
if you ever see
star trek or godzilla or any of these
movies there's always
a japanese man the in the same guy that
i i always
you know whenever i saw clyde on a movie
back in the 80s i'm like oh there's that
guy again
because i guess being in a minority you
just kind of cling on to
people that look like you so there was a
host of five
dudes that were working you know i mean
so um i
became friends with clyde he's a great
guy but it was so maybe that would have
been an angle that he could have used is
that what you're saying yeah
right because that that that sits deeply
with you yeah
in fact that was one of the first
stories you told me about the character
that you were playing
yeah yeah you're probably right i would
have done that i have no shame that's
what it kind of comes down to
i'll just like i was scared i was like
andrew i hate asking favors but like
i really want bobby we all really want
bobby he was the top
on the casting director's list we just
got the call
he's out we all feel so good we were all
so
bummed i'm sorry and then the next day
you were on doughboys another one of my
favorite podcasts i'm like [ __ ] this is
rubbing in my face
oh you gotta somehow get to bob but it's
not even like that but it's like
i've noticed you recently too because
last week you called me
right and i didn't respond to you i know
you know how does that feel
it felt fine okay thank you i knew you
saw it i i figured
yeah i did see it i have a reminder when
you're recording this podcast
to attempt to remind you about the uh
special so you talk about it i literally
have a weekly reminder
yeah so you know i want